good morning Hank it's Tuesday you'll
never guess where I am I'm in an airport
I was last in this airport so recently
that my login to the wireless hasn't
expired okay so yesterday subbable was
acquired by patreon that was great news
in more great news today is the
publication day of holding me closer
David Levithan musical novel companion
to the book we wrote together will
Grayson Will Grayson it's like the
actual tiny Cooper musical from Will
Grayson Will Grayson it's fantastic and
an even more great news the Paper Towns
trailer comes out on Thursday which is
why I'm in the airport because I have to
go beyond the Today Show also 100% of my
current children have vomited on me in
the past 24 hours so I'm a little
nervous that I might get a stomach bug
and then throw up on the Today Show
which would be very problematic on a
number of fronts but especially like the
Jets I just keep imagining the gifs of
me throwing up on Matt Lauer anyway
given the forthcoming release the
trailer I've been thinking a lot about
the phrase Paper Towns like in the book
it means different things to Q the
narrator at different points in the
story but in real life as you know Hank
the phrase Paper Towns is about coffee
right like mapmakers create fictitious
entries in their map to make sure that
no one else is copying them like if you
put my fake place on your map I know
that you've stolen from me
every map company does the sank like
Google Maps does it all the time they
probably created a paper town called
Argyll ttan in England but you see it
all the time it's usually not Paper
Towns it's usually like paper streets or
paper bridges my favourite example of
this aside from Aguila New York the one
that I use in Paper Towns is bateau sue
Ohio which is a town created by map
makers who were fans of the University
of Michigan's football team and wanted
them to beat OSU but Hank these
copyright traps aren't just limited to
map making you see them everywhere in
encyclopedias in dictionaries in
paleontology textbooks like in Paper
Towns Margo's dog is named Myrna Mount
Wiesel in honor of this fictitious entry
from the new Columbia encyclopedia about
Willy in Virginia mount weasel the
encyclopedia said that she was a
fountain designer and photographer who
died in an explosion while on assignment
for combustibles magazine I'm just
totally fascinated by how much fictional
information is floating around in the
non fictional world you know like Google
recently used fictitious entries against
Bing the Billboard charts have used them
but my favorite example comes from the
New Oxford American Dictionary the word
Esquith essence nope it's Esquiva glance
I'm sorry sometimes I mix up my
non-existent words at school violence or
maybe it's a valley until occurs
to me that I have no idea
how to pronounce this fictional word
anyway it's defined as avoiding one's
official responsibilities you know as a
thieving lexicographer would and the
crazy thing about SQL valiance is that
like agloe New York and many other
fictitious entries it is kind of become
real like it's in a bunch of
dictionaries now and the Apple
dictionary even gives it a fictional
etymology not like obviously this is an
appealing idea for a writer because I
need to believe that made-up stories can
really matter in the lives of real
people but it also reminds me that yes
obviously language shapes the dictionary
but the dictionary also shapes the
language I think I guess I kind of think
it is the official responsibility of us
as human beings to try to imagine the
world around us as complexly and
interestingly as we can and on that
front at least let us endeavor not to be
Esquiva liened I hope you like the Paper
Towns movie trailer comes out on
Thursday I will see you on Friday